hello and welcome to this video playing
lay on 28 I am lay on 28 m enough al
Mendoza from Colombia ok from English
opening rune trails down and normally
black takes them ok he didn't yeah h4 h5
and third it is interesting in this
position it's a little bit unusual but I
think it should have white as black skin
position is potentially insecure I'm a
bit surprised here let that should be
good I have f4 f5 now here the inclusion
of the H pawns clearly fatal avoid so i
also have a five-year nike5 orders f5
idea immediately trying to punish him
[Music]
it's definitely going to place these six
in the near future I wonder
I wonder if I can do something directly
here like with these six yeah f6 is
basically a sorry c6 is basically they
only move now and now it's a little bit
different that i have e 6 available here
let's do it this isn't a problem without
the h pawns plight but here i might have
some interesting ideas i was thinking i
take and play Queen stay tuned and now
g6 is a weakish and it has f5 simply
just at five now yeah it looks good if I
take Queen takes as Bishop takes h4 h5
as a as a threat
looks very dangerous for work so okay
yeah i think im just winning him to be
honest truck t1 or long castles what's
better Lowell casuals follow me
not sure okay yeah they just lose us I
thought 95 is a bit more more
interesting I take and play Bishop your
form yeah I just I'm just winning
opinion yeah yeah that that that was
really am I think he played it tattoo
too quickly not appreciating that the H
pawn make a big difference really this
position is already i think pretty much
toast for like there is there is a
similar line but i don't think it works
with the age for played so let's have a
look takes takes i can switch that on
yeah the engine is already pretty much
stating that like us in trouble yeah so
yeah nigeria okay if you have to go
night you for things are really really
bad TM they are you five yeah it's
difficult not to place is 60 as e6 is a
threat anyway so c6 and now the engine
wants to take on no queen bees frame is
that not good I am so taking allied l6l
is playable according to the comp
not fun but ok like this yeah linearity
ok this is ok so maybe actually is six
isn't the best m-maybe I should take
first then and play from here I can play
the screen c 2 of course intending oops
intending you six and if it does that i
have also 90 form layout pretty good so
probably this is the real problem then
that's for this position Quincy to 195
is still ok so even this position is
still ok for black huh I was really
thinking this is this is garbage but ok
long castles some oil too tricky move em
you don't think about long carefully me
all that much but of course it works him
and this is just losing yeah yeah I was
thinking that defies would continue a
little bit better but ok I can I can of
course take stuff yeah oh so that I
didn't play it right here and the main
thing was that I did not think about
this in the oil I mean he also didn't
but I don't quite understand why I
should be worth here but I can I love
take this night c4
i takes you three of the problem okay
the game was check check I'm just in the
Styles this yeah it's still a deadly pen
ok ok guys thanks for watching
[Music]